can't do it
and what i like about you too is you
also put a lot of accountability on men
you you don't just hold women
accountable you hold men accountable too
what are the common complaints you hear
from women about men and how can men
improve in their relationships
uh good god that's a well i don't really
get too many complaints uh about
sorry about valid complaints
oh valid complaints yeah yes um i don't
know
women complain about everything what are
some of the most common complaints about
men i mean i don't know i suppose uh you
know you hear this stuff men ain't [ __ ]
they're broke uh they're cheaters blah
blah blah blah i mean i think that uh
women like to complain when men try to
move the goal posts on them so they're
they enter into i don't care if it's a
casual relationship a relationship or
whatever they're dating their friends
with benefits whatever
but
all of a sudden he's willing to accept
ex behavior but then as time goes on you
can't say okay that was okay before but
that's not okay now that's exactly right
um so it's really important to to set
those set your boundaries set your
expectations
enlighten her on your standards you know
over time don't just go in your first
day and be like i don't do this and i
don't do that absolutely you know it's
just it's a slow reveal
and as the slow reveal happens whether
she's going to accept that or not that's
fine but
you know how to categorize her but she
can never say oh well you didn't tell me
that i couldn't have male friends oh you
didn't tell me that you didn't you know
you didn't
you weren't okay with me doing girls
nights out um if if early in the
relationship it comes up and say yeah i
personally don't feel that committed
women you know women that i commit to
should be doing that well then she knows
ahead of time but you can't you can't
just say it's okay one day and then all
of a sudden she wants commitment and
then you all of a sudden drop a bunch of
rules on her i think that's gonna be
okay well here's here's here's why this
is not okay
it's because men are angling for
relationships first
as a man the biggest mistake you can
ever make in any interaction with women
is to angle for commitment first i'll
give you an example let's say pearl
let's say you found a car on let's just
say ebay you found a car for ten
thousand dollars right
you buy you you pay the ten thousand
dollars you get the car delivered to
your house and everything is cool you've
paid the money all the paperwork is done
except you don't have the title
let's let's let's then say a week later
the seller of the car the previous owner
says hey i know you paid the ten
thousand dollar asking price for the car
but for me to send you the title i'm
gonna need another five thousand dollars
you wouldn't pay that because it was
established in the beginning that in
order to possess what it was you wanted
you had to pay x amount of dollars which
was ten thousand dollars
this is the equivalent of angling for
commitment angling for commitment first
as a man and then laying the rules
the deal is this
when you ask a woman to be your
girlfriend you as a man are forfeiting
your you are forfeiting your right and
your ability to establish boundaries and
expectations because when you ask a
woman would you like to be my girlfriend
you are telling her directly actually
directly and indirectly that you have
now you have you have fulfilled all of
the requirements required to secure my
commitment
so a lot of so a lot of guys say hey
would you like to be my girlfriend
they're like oh yeah of course and girls
almost if if they really think they like
a guy if a girl if a guy asks her to be
oh yes of course she's going to say yes
because at that point she knows okay i
can take a deep breath now that i have
commitment
now now i can pretty much do whatever i
want
there you go and it's because it's
because he angled for relationship first
now a lot of guys might say well you're
the man you have to ask listen back in
the day that was true that is not true
today in 2022. in 2022 if you ask a
modern woman to be your girlfriend that
is a that that that is only going to
lead to a bad relationship because at
that point a woman looks looks at that
as a license to do whatever she wants
because you didn't establish boundaries
well donovan what if she never asks you
to be in a relationship then she doesn't
like you as much as you thought she did
at which point
at which point you continue to keep it
casual you can only you can only
establish boundaries when she angles for
a
relationship and i talk about this all
the time
women always say four or five months so
donovan what are we what are we what is
this this is their way of indirectly
asking you hey i want commitment
you need the very first or second time a
woman tries to angle for commitment you
need to put her off put her off put her
off she thinks she wants commitment
because either she really likes you or
she's tired of meeting your standards so
at that point you put her off a couple
times the third fourth time and if guys
have heard me say this all the time do
you want to know what it's like to be in
a relationship with with a guy like me
yes i really want to know okay unlock
your phone and hand it to me right now
okay dude 112 percent of women are like
oh my god i can't believe it blah blah
blah blah then they try to be slick and
say hey i'm ready to hand you my phone
the very next day not how it works honey
what that does is that shows her that in
order to be in a committed relationship
with me if you want my commitment you
are going to have to be 100 transparent
with me if i ask for your phone you give
it to me oh my god that's so insecure i
don't care what you call it that's a man
protecting himself because so many women
come into relationships being experts on
hiding their licentious [ __ ] behavior
they end up blindsiding guys out of
nowhere so it is incumbent upon men to
vet women thoroughly and establish from
the start if you want to be in a
relationship with a man like me this is
what's required so let's just say a
woman does pass this okay well i'm not
screwing anybody else here you go okay
well what about now well that's a start
oh my god what else do i have to do
funny you should ask
i'm not gonna tell you what you can or
can't do but i will tell you this
i don't commit to women who go to bars i
don't commit to women who go to clubs i
don't commit to women who stay in
contact with their ex i don't commit to
women who stay in contact with people
who've been inside them i don't commit
to women who travel alone i don't commit
to women on social media and on and on
and on and if it's just too much for her
to handle no problem don't don't take it
personally she just doesn't like you as
much as you thought she did there's no
need to take it personally like it is
what it is maybe she's not looking for
something that serious but then a lot of
girls are like oh my god that's too much
and then i say okay well let's say you
were dating i don't know chris hemsworth
you're dating chris hemsworth for six
months and he says uh by the way if you
want to be in a relationship with me i
know this is a bad australian accent
yeah i need you i need access to your
your your telephone i need access to
your cameras
yeah yeah exactly do you see that yeah
dude everyone yes chris please listen
you can hire a party
higher surveillance have me followed
i'll put a gps tracker in my coochie do
whatever you want and that's exactly the
point the reason why most women the
reason why all women would do that is
because of his value and that's exactly
the point your value dictates what a
woman is willing to what a woman is
willing to go through to secure your
commitment if you're not at the point
where you can start demanding these
things for women no problem we're men we
have time but do not sell yourself short
by angling for a relationship first with
women it dude it falls flat every single
time there are tons of men out there
whose wives and girlfriends do more for
their bosses or employers than they
would ever consider doing for their
husbands real talk
um so
ideally
when you're in a relationship with a
woman you want her
you want her to have you as her number
one right um as far as i'm willing to do
anything to make this work um and now
we're not talking about like sadistic
and abusive relationships we're talking
about healthy relationships that
requests have purposes to them um and
it's we're not just trying like
donovan's never asked me to do anything
that didn't have a purpose to it that
was just to see if i'd go ahead and do
it yeah
dude man you know like
when we first started when we first like
started dating and we were getting
serious
i went so far as to change my phone
number so anybody i talked to in the
past couldn't even get a hold of me like
i wanted a clean slate i wanted a fresh
start and i didn't want to have any of
those ghosts of the past skeletons in
the closet coming back to haunt me um
and and that was a way for me to protect
my new relationship with this per with
with donovan so
a lot of girls aren't willing to get off
social media they're not willing to you
know say i'm okay my guy friends they're
great they had their time and purpose it
doesn't belong here you know if they get
if they hook up with somebody maybe we
could do a double d
you know you can still interact with
people but it's got to be on a
respectable level to where you're
putting your relationship first um and a
lot of people just don't value the fact
that relationships need to be protected
no and i've always said to guys that if
like i don't know if you've ever had a
girl that's like obsessed with you
that's what i always say to guys like
i'm sure you could think of one girl off
the top of your head that was just like
that she would have did anything uh oh
my god you remember there was chrissy
dinara um
uh god daphne yeah yeah sugar tank in
here i guess
first yeah
girl i don't know oh oh god yeah but i
don't i don't remember her name but yeah
she was [ __ ] crazy well and i always
say you shouldn't settle for a girl
that's not that into you
okay it's a lot easier when they're
obsessed i mean there's lies you
shouldn't be like stuck in your house or
anything
well listen and it's funny when you say
obsessed you don't really mean obsessed
you just meet a woman who really really
likes you
and you have to have a woman who is
willing to
if if you want a woman if you want a
woman to really really make your life
better you need to have a woman who is
willing to do for you what she has never
done for any man i know that devin has
never done for any man well
i know that you don't know anything but
i'm willing to bet that it is far more
likely than not that devin has probably
never done for any man what she has done
for me i don't take anything for granted
including when it comes to my own woman
but that's really how a woman shows you
that she wants to be with you when she
is exhibiting behaviors that you know
she likely hasn't done in the past or
she's only done it with a few guys then
at that point you know she's really into
you
no i agree i think there's a lot of men
that women have just treated like crap
for a really long time and i think the
tides are turning i think men are
starting to wake up and realize they
don't have to accept this
and i think channels like yours are
really important because like you can he
decodes you know female nature in front
of you in real time and now he's giving
you instead of just talking about the
problem they're giving you a solution
yep yeah that's and you know what's
interesting every quote unquote red pill
content creator uh goes through weeks we
still go through the uh the red pill
phases
live and then living color when i first
came to youtube i was you know [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] and three signs she's a [ __ ]
and four signs she belongs to the
streets and all that good stuff and it's
evolved i mean i started when i was what
uh this was back in 2014
um and i'm not the world's greatest
mathematician but my content has evolved
as i've evolved i am dude my message has
never ever wavered it always stays the
same the delivery is is clearly
different but the message is always the
same now do i have some changes in
opinion as far as the operations within
my red bull of course of course you know
with time introspection things that you
learn along the way nobody has all of
the answers all at once i'm always
learning but i feel really good about
where i'm at in terms of my mindset
yeah no i think it's the same for women
when we find the red pill because at
first you're like
i mean you you saw some of my reactions
early where i'm just like well there's
this exact survey
but then you just start to realize like
like the red pill is talking about how
things generally are and how there's a
lot of big issues for men and it's not
maybe as individualistic because i think
women were sought what do they call it
solacism yes solipsism
yeah they only think of things from
their point of view yeah